brian is with us in greenville south
carolina hey brian how can we help
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
so my question today actually is advice
on what to do with our tax return
um we've got about six thousand planning
on coming in from that
and um we're on baby step two so
we're choosing debt to pay off but
at the same time we just bought a house
at the beginning of this year and it
it's an older house 1957. and
the inspector said that the ac unit
actually is on its last life
and that it would probably be going out
soon and we've made it
thus far in the winter but
it from the outside it looks it looks
pretty bad and so
i'm worried that it'll go out if we
spend this tax return
we'll end up having to come up with
money to replace that
so uh let's say you're in greenville
south carolina
and it is february yeah
you don't need an ac yeah not too bad
well it's it's i know i'm poking fun at
you
right so if it goes out in july you go
to walmart and buy a ten dollar box fan
okay how much debt have you got left
well not including the house it's about
30 000.
okay what's your household income sir
uh only about 26 to 30. for you and your
wife combined income my wife is a
stay-at-home mom that's kind of getting
paid under the table to babysit okay and
what it what are you
and so you're working 40 hours yeah how
old are you
26. what do you do uh forklift driver
for a local warehouse
okay okay all right so what are you
going to be doing when you're 30 that
makes twice what you make now
that's a good question i've i had
surgery a couple years ago
and it's really limiting my options as
to what i can do so i'm still actually
in the process of trying to figure out
what i can do so it affected you
physically but not mentally
yeah okay so you're gonna do something
that's called white collar
okay right using your brain
yeah any education brian
uh three years of i.t but no graduate
okay all right so why are you not
working in it
um because in college i took the same
math class
about three times and wasn't able to
pass it with a high enough degree to
continue in the
core class in the degree classes yeah
but what did you learn did you learn
programming
a little bit of programming and uh
networking
okay so even if you couldn't pass the uh
the math class can you work on a
computer yeah
yes sir i pays more than driving a
forklift
most likely yeah like definitely brian
let me answer this question man
i don't i'm listening to you and i
i don't hear motivation i don't hear
aspiration i don't hear like yo i really
want to do more
like what why why are you living today
like where where do you see yourself
what do you want in the next 10 15 years
well to be honest all the things i
wanted to do i can't i wanted to join
the military i wanted to be in the
police force or something like that
that's more physical
and so i didn't really have a back-up
plan when i heard that i need to be off
my feet
and i t i was never excited about
because that's
um one of my biggest weaknesses is being
a gamer and so
i didn't feel like it would be a good
idea to
be in front of a computer all day you
know with the
chances of getting into different gaming
stuff or whatever
plus i like to be more hands-on so i
didn't want to really be in an office if
i could help it
got you so you're going to be in an
office yeah because you're not going to
be in the military and you're going to
get off this forklift
yeah and you're going to be doing you're
going to be a software engineer dude
yeah i mean if you love gaming won't we
take all those skills and that love and
let's use it for something
the reason we're going into this is it
solves your air conditioner problem
yes because you don't have an air
conditioner problem you have an income
problem
right that's why we went there
okay so we're going to get the cattle
prod and
zap you off that forklift ready
you feel it so i want you i want you
by uh this time a seat
by the first of march i want you to have
talked to
three people in the technical world
about you doing some side help for them
while you keep your day job yes
i want you to stick your toe in the
water and reset your dream
you're too young to have your only dream
destroyed and you do nothing the rest of
your life
you have too much potential there's too
much for you to do in this world
yeah god was not surprised that you got
hurt and he has a plan for you
right mm-hmm and
i don't there's nothing there's no shame
in driving a forklift
but i don't think you're there because
it's your passion to drive a forklift i
think you're there because you're hiding
yeah yeah and it was the easiest answer
yeah like it was a different operating
equipment it was default
it was whatever program came up when you
turned it on yeah
yeah and here's the thing brian dave
told you something that's key and i do
not want you to miss it and before you
hang up i want you to stand online
because kelly
is going to give you one of our friends
ken coleman's uh book the proximity
principle
he told you to talk to three people in
the tech world and work for them on the
side
what's key is there is that not only
will you get income on the side but
you're going to build relationships
what if you could make 200 000 a year
working for a company that creates games
that's it and that starts with the
relationships as a gamer
well i think that would be better than
any plan you had
absolutely probably even the other plan
that was your glory plan
yeah i mean it's because you love gaming
and your brain works that way i know
that because you gravitated towards tech
yeah none of this was an accident yeah
so hey man i just i i want good things
for you okay so what i'm gonna tell you
is i'm gonna tell you take that six
thousand dollars
and pay it on your debt and i want you
to get an extra job in the tech world
and pay off your debt even faster and
while you're working that extra job if
your air conditioner goes out this
summer
you can stop your debt snowball for a
little bit work 100 hours a week
and uh at the extra tech job and then
buy you an air conditioner
yeah but right now i want you to work in
the debt snowball but dude
this is not about your debt snowball i
think we got a hold of it it's about
your career track
and hold on kelly's going to pick up
we're going to give you a copy of ken
coleman's book go to kencoleman.com
his website download all of his stuff
it's all free
and we gave you the only thing he
charges for which is the book
and he will walk you through how to get
this going man yeah
and uh but it's exactly what you need to
do you need to start poking around the
career the tech world
and get off that forklift because that's
not going to take you where you want to
go
it's not because it wasn't your goal i
mean i got a friend that owns a forklift
company if you want to own a forklift
company you can do it yeah
if you that's what you want to do but i
don't think that was your plan
nah you can hear it all in his voice
dave and that's one thing
well time is up but you called him out i
did you called him out i didn't call him
about that you just
heard the bus bus threw him under the
bus
for his own good though that was a bus a
love bus yes